there was a fascinating moment on
propaganda Network Fox News over the
weekend if you've watched this program
before and if you haven't in your on our
YouTube channel for the first time
please make sure you are subscribing to
the channel we're trying to get to 1
million subscribers but if you've
watched before you know that sometimes
Shepard Smith or Chris Wallace will make
at least like a little sense on Fox News
and they'll cut short or short-circuit
some obvious lie here or there and it's
a good thing when they do it and I have
an example for you today but this is
more than just sort of conflict porn
which is what a lot of corporate media
likes to do here's what I want you to
understand about what I'm gonna play for
you today the Trump administration and
the people around Trump are telling lies
all the time
about just basic knowable facts these
are not lies hidden in political
rhetoric or selective statistics these
are just straight-up demonstrable lies
and in the clip I'm going to play for
you today Donald Trump's chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney went on Fox News Sunday he
was interviewed by fox's Chris Wallace
and Mulvaney tried to assert he claimed
that Muller's testimony effectively is
an exoneration of Donald Trump remember
they've been claiming that molars report
is an exoneration of Donald Trump which
it's not and now they are claiming that
Robert molars testimony is an
exoneration of Donald Trump which it's
not and they get into a back-and-forth
about
Omo ler said there was no way Trump was
getting indicted no matter what for what
he did this is an exoneration de facto
and in a lot of places Donald Trump's
cronies the people around him the
brown-nosing sycophants as I like to
call them they've been getting away with
this stuff and even on Fox News they
usually get away with these types of
lies it goes unchallenged and then it
becomes part of the de facto status quo
narrative this is how propaganda works
Fox News doesn't have to perpetuate the
propaganda themselves even though they
do in many cases they can simply stand
aside while the Trump administration
creates it this is why I believe in
responsible platforming this is why when
I interview an extremist like whoever as
many many times have done before
I don't have to agree with what they say
I can make the problem worse merely by
standing aside and letting them say
their thing which is why I don't do that
when I do interviews with radicals and
extremists that's why this is so
important this is a small victory that
Chris Wallace short-circuits this let's
take a look at the video Muller answered
the single one outstanding question he
said what they asked him would you have
indicted the president if he were not
the president and and Muller said
absolutely not he would not do that he
answered indirectly that's not what he
said he'd you know that isn't what he
said he said we didn't because of the
OLC the Office of Legal Counsel
guidelines he said we could didn't even
make a decision he got asked a question
by congressman Lew who I know said would
you indicted him if he were not the
president and that he said yes we would
have any went back to the beginning of
the second hearing and and and that's
when he said we couldn't
he said we yes he did race but what he
said was that we I wouldn't I wouldn't
have made it we didn't even make that
decision because the guidelines
prevented us from doing that I actually
just think you're wrong on that if they
could record will show what a charge if
they had to promise you you're wrong so
Mulvaney wants to parrot this idea that
Muller vindicated Donald Trump even
though the opposite was actually said at
the hearings so let's look at the
transcript a Jerry Nadler during the
hearing said so the report did not
conclude that he did not commit
obstruction of justice is that correct
Moeller says that is correct and Nadler
adds and what about total exoneration
did you actually totally exonerate the
president relevant because that's what
Trump has been claiming Moeller says no
Nadler adds now in fact your report
expressly states that it does not
exonerate the President and Moeller
confirms it does
- which Nadler adds and your
investigation actually found quote
multiple acts by the president that were
capable of exerting undue influence over
law enforcement investigations including
the Russian interference and obstruction
investigations is that correct - which
Moeller says correct this is why we have
to interrupt the echo chamber at any
point where we have an opportunity to do
that because this is how propaganda
spreads
nah when we talk about Donald Trump and
the way in which he uses Twitter a lot
of his Twitter use a more interesting
analysis of his Twitter use I will say
is not about the content of each tweet
per se but about the way in which Donald
Trump will use Twitter to start tweeting
the exact same stuff that his chief of
staff will go on Fox News and say and
that then some right-wing activist a
commentator will do a blog post about
and Donald from junior will retweet this
is how they foam at that icky echo
chamber the way that the propaganda
machine works is obfuscate and
mischaracterize as much as you can I
call that line you could use those
softer terms obfuscate and miss
character characterize if you want in
order to make the truth very difficult
to even find because you're wading
through all sorts of conflicting
statements then once you've inserted
your narrative into the broader
discussion which is there's nothing to
see here
you start to misdirect and distract with
things like Baltimore is infested as an
example and then in other cases you
simply say nothing altogether you go
totally silent as if the issue not exist
doesn't exist which is actually a really
effective way to short-circuit the media
narrative because if media can't get
people to react to something it becomes
very difficult to continue that story on
and on and on that's the broader way in
which the propaganda model works and
Chris Wallace I mean listen I'm not
gonna go around telling you Chris
Wallace is the best person around but to
the extent that he at least
short-circuited this one minor element
of Donald Trump's cronies trying to
spread propaganda lies I think better
said we should commend him for it make
sure that you are following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show and while you're there follow me as
well at David Pakman
I finally got finally I've got a tomato
plant I've been monitoring and watering
and pruning for three months and I
finally got some Tomatoes there's a
picture on my Instagram go check it out
David Pakman right back after this if
you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david
when show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video